you thought he was gone you thought he
had been vanquished
you thought he was just circling around
a whataburger parking lot on his
skateboard
he lost his race
for texas senator to ted cruz
he lost his race
for president
pretty early on despite a lot of
establishment support in 2020 you know
who i'm talking about
america's favorite fake mexican beto
o'rourke who is now running for governor
of texas if at first and second you
don't succeed try and try and try and
try and try again
beto o'rourke is running for texas
governor on a platform
of transiting
the kids
beto o'rourke just just released a new
ad about how gung-ho he is
to finally fulfill the will of texas
voters
by transiting the
kids in the education system of texas i
was wondering what you were going to do
to protect my rights and my parents
rights to be able to put me on
testosterone the trans suicide rate has
been the highest it's ever been in texas
since those bills have been placed i
mean we're seeing people trying to take
their lives right now and it's a tough
thing for us to talk about but you're
right we should say it out loud so we
speak about everyone in this state with
pride we talk about a texas that is big
enough for all of us we target no one
based on any difference between us
whether it is the color of your skin
your country of national origin or the
fact that you are non-binary i think
you're amazing i'm proud of you i want
you to do great things in this state
and i'm going to support you in doing
that and i'm going to say that publicly
as the governor of this state that's
going to be a big change for texas it
just feels like he would be defending me
and caring about my rights as a trans
non-binary person it feels like he'd
care and he'd actually listen to our
voices and our thoughts about everything
beta o'rourke ran in 2020 on a platform
of hell yes we are going to take your
ar-15s
and now in 2022 he's running for
governor on a platform of
hell yes we are going to take your
gonads
yes
hell yes we're going to trans your kids
this is very important you're amazing
you're amazing you're amazing wait hold
on
hold on
the the confused people that beto
o'rourke was talking to there and the
radical sexual activists that beto
o'rourke was talking to there
they might be perfectly nice people i
don't know i don't know them
they might be productive members of
society if they're showing up to beto
o'rourke rallies i highly doubt it
but maybe they are
maybe they volunteer and do good stuff
maybe i don't know maybe they you know
helped little old ladies across the
street
why are they amazing
they're amazing because they don't know
what sex they are or they're pretending
to be a different sex or they're
insisting that we get rid of bathrooms
for women or they're insisting we get
rid of women's and that's amazing
why is that amazing
am i amazing because i have swarthy skin
am i amazing because i have uh
what two or three inches of hair
a little quaff is that
am i amazing because of some
way that i present myself to the world
no what it's not it's not really amazing
beethoven is pandering here i guess the
only the thing that is amazing really
it
this goes deeper than anything beto
o'rourke has ever been able to think in
his entire life but there is something
amazing about the transgender issue
which is one
as a biological matter this affects very
very few people i have i can listen i
have no doubt this is a fallen world
some people are born with nine fingers
and eleven toes some people are bored
people are born with all sorts of quirks
because we're all we've all got
imperfections and so sure i'm sure
there's some biological basis for all
sorts of sexual pathologies and
confusions
there's also obviously a social aspect
here you look at gen gen z the zoomers
40 of them four zero percent of them
identify as lgbt so either alex jones is
right and there's something in the water
turning all of the freaking frogs gay or
there's a social aspect here that's not
really rooted in any kind of born this
way or or natural or even even
you know
natural environmental factor that's
going on
but what's what's amazing here
is that
as technology advances
the physical aspects of our lives seem
to matter less and less and less
you you hear this from our ruling elites
all around the world not just in our
country from but all around the world
the world economic forum talking about
the great reset right where they say
you're going to work from home a lot
more you're not going to go to an office
you're not going to see people too much
you hear it from facebook where mark
zuckerberg says you're not going to go
to bars and meetings and birthday
parties and weddings you're just you're
going to sit in your little apartment
and you're going to put goggles on and
you're going to live in a candyland
world that i made myself and then you're
going to interact with cartoon versions
of people you're going to leave the real
world created by god for your
flourishing and you're going to go into
a creepy video game invented by a lizard
person named mark zuckerberg that's a
isn't that a great trade
why would you want this world with you
know the over the brave or hanging
firmament
the the majestical roof fretted with
stars the beautiful wildlife the flora
the fauna everything
all of our real
loves and hopes and joys why would you
live in that world given to us by our
incomprehensible all-loving creator when
you can live in a weird video game made
by a human lizard wouldn't that be in
your little pod that you don't you're
not allowed to leave because you know
there are germs outside where you just
eat the bugs it's very important they're
a good source of protein make sure you
eat the bugs
our elites tell us isn't that great and
your physical body
in this hellish dystopia
does not matter as much
and what transgenderism says is
your body doesn't matter as much yeah my
body i look like a man i talk like a man
got this
deep slightly gravelly voice because my
allergies are acting up it's not just
one too many cigars but you can see i've
got an adam's apple i look like a fella
but deep down
i'm really a lady and that's that's all
there is to it
agnostic heresy
as i said it all
we get dumber every year we get in our
modern world we've never been so stupid
because what we're seeing with this
transgenderism issue is nothing more
than the same old gnostic heresy that's
been going on for thousands of years and
every few hundred years every 500 years
or so rears its ugly head to try to
destroy civilization
beto o'rourke made an important point
there
he said texas is big enough for
everybody
sure i mean i the thing is that there's
no such thing as a transgender
non-binary person i'm not saying the
people who believe that they are that
don't exist but it's a category error
that category of person doesn't exist
it's a delusion and delusions should not
be
encouraged
but is it is it bigot is texas big
enough it's not big enough for all these
ideas march 2nd is ash wednesday over a
billion people will start living
different in some way maybe giving up
chocolate or alcohol or whatever for a
lot of folks lent is a time of finding
the easiest way to give something
but at the end of those 40 days did that
sacrifice really make a difference this
year there's a new opportunity out there
specifically for men it will actually
help you grow closer to god and become a
better man you might have heard me talk
about exodus 90 but let me tell you
about exodus lent a 40-day journey that
will challenge you to dig a little
deeper this year here's how it works
first over the 40 days of lent men
commit to daily prayer setting aside a
minimum of 20 minutes to spend with the
lord each day includes a scripture
reading and reflection written to help
men better understand grow in and live
virtue second more than just giving up
chocolate
men take up a range of disciplines and
sacrifices for the season of lent sweets
snacks social media all gone third men
commit to a fraternity of five to seven
men each week the fraternity meets to
pray together check in hold each other
accountable and encourage one another on
easter sunday you'll walk away with a
new and lasting understanding of what it
means to live the full christian life
chocolate bunnies and all sign up now at
exodus 90.com
michael i'm glad you like that clip i
like that clip too now
ring the bell subscribe you have to
subscribe you must
do it that way you will get
notifications also probably the better
way to do it head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe to the michael noel show leave
a five star review we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you